Democrats desperately trying to explain
away Carl Lago as Joe Biden heads back
to his Delaware house this weekend to
reorganize his garage Fallout still
coming in hot over the president's
mishandling of classified documents
which forced his own doj to appoint a
special counsel the New York Post asks
anybody vet this guy Yep looks like
things are pretty secure in there the
FBI is said to be grilling Biden AIDS
about how top secret files ended up next
to his Corvette and Republican Jim
Jordan says his first order of business
will be getting to the bottom of it
we're also learning the same house was
Hunter's hangout Pat that's right the
drug loving first son lived at the
property for years and even had his
credit card statement sent there we all
know Hunter would never be careless with
sensitive information it's no wonder the
Democrats don't want to talk about it
President Biden had classified documents
in his Wilmington garage is just
breaking do you think that's
irresponsible and Reckless of him it's
irresponsible is to not disclose when
you have documents he has certainly done
that Biden people are bringing forth the
documents they're not obstructing access
to them or knowledge about them why did
she not inform the American public two
months ago do you think that was a
mistake well I don't know what you're
saying right now you see much more
measured about this than with the Trump
documents because you call for
transparency with a trump document
bottom line is I said that night it's
premature to comment on what should be
done
and neither does President Biden
[Music]
and the White House is still very
tight-lipped over all this and wouldn't
even call on our own very Peter Ducey
who
I mean our very own stupid son of a
[ __ ] who makes this interesting point
how do you think his mother if I would
have had an opportunity to ask a
question it the first one that I have on
my sheet was uh why is President Biden
going to Wilmington today uh isn't that
a potential crime scene
I mean the FBI was just there the other
day yeah that's right and you know the
question the amazing part of all of this
is that you know we know that the left
decides look there really is nothing to
see here and but the issue is not the
number of inadvertently misplaced
documents it's not whether uh the the
there were so few or whether he's fully
cooperating the issue is whether or not
he had documents and he was grossing
negligence in not keeping them in the
proper storage area that's it end of the
story so I don't know why all of a
sudden there's this what about isn't but
I got to tell you something what I want
to know if Hunter Biden Justin lived in
that house where there were documents in
the garage and by the way the garage
door has been left open in the past
that's already been reported on and the
documents are right there the documents
have been there at least six years
because it's been six years since Joe
Biden was the vice president then the
question is who had access to those
documents and if Hunter was living there
I want someone to fingerprint those
documents I want those documents
fingerprinted so I know that Hunter
Biden has definitely not touched them
because I suspect that there's more to
it and in addition now we've got three
locations in addition to the garage
there's another location in the house
and Korean Jean-Pierre is no longer a
press secretary who's worthy of
credibility because she knew on
Wednesday that there was an additional
location of these documents and let me
say finally that the Biden
Administration in the presidential they
weren't even Administration the
presidential election they shut down the
hunter behind the laptop okay they
didn't want anyone to know about it in
something like 52 percent of Americans
voted said it would have changed their
votes in a very close election now we've
got them doing the same thing before a
midterm hiding what the Department of
Justice and the White House knew and
they are now like they're gaslighting
the American people and finally I think
that it is worth asking how and why this
story is breaking now is this some of
the Dems who don't want Joe Biden to run
everybody's known about this for months
in Washington now are they leaking it so
they can say you know what the vote of
right here is we're going to tank Joe
Biden and get him the hell out do you
find that suspicious Geraldo
you mean the timing of the timing and
maybe the Democrats I I forgive me
ladies and gentlemen I am so sorry that
I am so scornful of this story I think
that it is a big waste of time I think
that you should scold both of these guys
you should revoke their library cards it
is absolutely and let's get on with life
all of this hubris all of this energy
all of this money the special counsels I
predict that you're going to see the
special cat it's going to be like a
sparkler on July 4th it's going to go
and then it's going to be stop burning
down burning Denver and then then it's
gonna then they'll be on to some other
so you're saying Trump or by nothing's
going to happen I think nothing should
happen I'm not saying nothing is going
to happen I think that when you examine
what is what is this exactly what
happened here the presidents of the
United States took some stuff they
thought was theirs because they wanted
to ego stroke or write a book or
whatever it was President
he was vice president enough
I I I and then there's a legal term and
then they just kept them and ignored
them and how many people have boxes that
you put in the garage and you leave them
there and they get wet and they use
steps
believe me that box is in the well I
think boxes and garages are an
indication of how important the vice
president thought this was well he said
he takes it very seriously our box is in
a garage getting wet taking it seriously
Geraldo I think that I I do not take it
seriously I'm sorry I will I will sit in
Washington DC I will watch
all of your rage and all of the emotions
and all of the engagement that you're
Joe Biden goes to to meet with the
Ukrainian prime minister and president
four days before President Trump takes
office what's that about what kind of
deals do they have cooking Geraldo
doesn't have an answer to that Cyrus do
you have any answers you know what I
have been watching just riveting
journalism on what your show and you
last night you created an epiphany in my
head and you tied this all together in
one nice little bow Judge Jeanine you
are correct they are all connected to
one thing what is the one thing in
common Hunter Biden the big guy probably
didn't know who had those classified
documents because he gave his son one
job get rid of the stuff that connects
to the big guy and he was supposed to
throw the gun in the garage and he was
supposed to put the documents in the
trash he had one job and leave the
cannoli and unfortunately yes he messed
it up and he hit it he had access we
know how many times he's been to the
White House to see to see the big guy
we're seeing all the connections and all
this in the tight bow is going to lead
to the indictment of Hunter for what he
did which will then to your point Scorn
the little girl that he made take a bus
when she didn't want to Kamala revenge
is best served cold so if all comes at
night he will pardon his son and resign
Kamala gets the thing in one tight
little bow oh wow you know you know what
that would be one special moment laptop
we've got I'm telling you all right you
know what bothers the American people
about this there's a double standard
right Geraldo thinks that everybody
these guys should you know leave them
alone no big deal Hillary had a 110
email chains with several uh top secret
documents among them and we're just
supposed to say it's okay and Jim Comey
gets up and says you know we're not
gonna but of course we're not going to
prosecute in this case then you've got
all these other folks right a former
civilian employee of the defense
department these were put together by
Jim Garrity spent three months in prison
for bringing classified documents back
to their house another one 18 months in
prison and a ten thousand dollar fine
for the crime of willfully retaining
National Defense information another one
got nine years in a federal prison so
Geraldo can you explain that was the
nine years is it is why do the rules not
pertain to the former president or to
this President I will I will answer your
question with a question how do you feel
about the fact that Janine points out
that this was the day before the
midterms or something like that the the
uh the purported proximity makes it so
relevant and so important what if
this election coming up or the the
candidacy of either of these gentlemen
turns on this crap
on on negligence this had you're not the
president United States was not a and
the vice president United States would
they weren't shoplifters they weren't
Crooks they they weren't uh they were
sloppy wait formerly
what about the fact that Hillary and Joe
when these things happened all their
donations went up into them this is
Benghazi foreign country this is
Benghazi this is Benghazi again and then
Hillary Clinton and where does it go it
was nope you're not answering my
question why do these civilians have to
follow the law of the United States of
America why is it that these individuals
think that they're Above the Law and I
heard Nancy Pelosi screaming about the
fact that you know no one is above the
law Hillary Clinton no one is above the
law when it came to Donald Trump why are
they not above the law and why in this
case
together if I'm leaving the White House
and I've got classified documents I'm
going guys check everything I'm not
walking out of here with anything this
is a lot different than a civil servant
who who's trying to save himself some
wear and tear yes by taking something
home
that that's an arrogant move by a
bureaucrat who deserves to have his
wrists left and why is this not an
arrogant Bureau because he was the vice
president United States or the president
of the United States that you have to
give them a little vice president he's
the vice president of the United States
where National Security is the top issue
right now and this guy is not only in
bed with China and getting money from
China through his son he's got the 10
we're talking Nationals were you this
passionate when it was Mar-A-Lago and
president Trump president Trump is not
in bed with Russia China or anybody else
really even minus politics it's not
about politics it's about this country
and we're losing this country hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else